he's Sean Payton the Saints head coach
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
coach joins us now I was just talking
about being on the podium when you know
handing up the Lombardi Trophy what do
you remember after you guys won when you
were on the podium well I think you know
it's it's kind of that euphoria you know
and enjoying the ultimate team's success
at the end of the season either you know
there's so much goes through your mind
just in regards to the you know the
journey to get there and you know after
experience at all experiencing at all
and in talking to young players about
you know what what you think it's like
it's it's a hundred times better and but
when somebody says you know What's it
feel like it feels like that's an easy
question to ask but but we are curious
that you know you've waited all your
coaching life for that moment and you
end up beating Peyton Manning and you
won the Super Bowl and you had an onside
kick that people thought you were
probably crazy attempting and then all
of a sudden you're up there and then
somebody says hey well how's it feel
because you don't know it until you get
up there yeah it's it's it's a hundred
times better than then you might even
imagine you know you're you're you're so
happy for the players you know all the
people that year was unique in that that
time frame was unique because it was
also a little bit more tied to the city
with with regard to rebuild post-katrina
and that made it a that much more
special but I do remember it's the only
time where you don't get to address your
team after a game you know even the NFC
championship game when you come back in
you had that moment in the locker room
where you're together and you're
prepping for next week and you have some
announcements and you know you're going
to a Super Bowl but that game ends and
the buses all still wait there's five
buses but one by one players coaches end
up in
locker room you know cleaned up showered
and getting on the buses so there's
there's not that that last time as a
team you know and I do remember very
clearly the bus ride from the stadium to
the hotel and there is a little post
partum in that we're not playing anymore
like you just want to keep playing
because you're into such a schedule and
you're enjoying the process you know
that each each day of preparing for the
next opponent that there is that moment
where you want that bus ride to last two
hours instead of 25 minutes or half an
hour it's interesting and yeah you do
feel like man it's it's over there's no
more games to play there's no one else
left
he said Sean Sean Payton the Saints head
coach joining us Continental Tire
Coach's Corner you got a chance to see
Anthony Davis in person could you use
him on a football field man I'd sure
like to try the we had Jimmy Graham you
know did you could you see that I think
I I think Alban I'd have a little bit of
a beef even walk anywhere near we're
only separated by 200 yards and and yet
we might share the cafeteria
periodically but I've really you know
over the years now and look I get two
maybe three or four games a year to
watch and the other night just happened
to be courtside and in it's it's amazing
to see the athleticism and the size and
with with Anthony you know he's gotten
bigger and you you there's a presence
with him close to the basketball who
where you can feel his physicality and I
don't know when you're one that that was
the case certainly the athleticism was
present but each year he's he's gotten
better and man they're they're playing
such good defense right now I in that
series
early on especially the games in
Portland I mean the regardless of how
they were shooting you just felt like
the stops they were getting on defense
and the transition points they were
getting you know I think at this time
the year in that in that sport that wins
in the night you don't shoot as well
from the three or you don't shoot as
well from the free-throw line or or
whatever the way they're playing on
defense I think is is going to serve
them well not only in the series they
just played but I think in the in the
upcoming series and certainly there'll
be challenges if in fact it's gold
estate who they have to play but but I
think holidays a different players you
watch them right now than then you know
last year or the year before and it's
exciting to watch let me let me talk
about the draft you you made some
headlines and now I've been paraphrasing
you but I want you to put it in your own
words I think it was how many you know
what do you think of this quarterback
draft and who's gonna be a franchise
quarterback and once again paraphrasing
that it felt like if anybody emerges as
a franchise quarterback it'll be Sam
Donald is that fair to what you were
saying yeah I I think so III think this
we were just going through last year's
first round and if you took out last
year's first round and you went through
the selection with each team again and
then asked the question would they do it
again would they make the same selection
I think you'd have 15 to 18 to 20 knows
I mean it this is last season and the
last year's draft there's a few to be
determined and then there probably be a
yeses and with regards to the
quarterback class this year I mean this
is this is just us the Saints you know
the guy we had graded very high last
year was my homes and
you know your prior went and you just
keep going back luck and I don't know
that I see that player in this class and
I think I thought you were taking a
homeless but was there any thought of
getting the home so I thought you were
gonna you were gonna get him he was a
target at 11:00 he he was definitely in
our 11 cloud the only thing that
happened that we weren't expecting
although you kind of aren't surprised
anytime when you're when you're
selecting that early when it got down to
a lotta more you know you keep this
bubble right on the board in front of
you and you know that you're on pick
eight and you might have four in this
bubble and then one goes and another
goes and then here here it was picked
ten and we have two players in the
bubble
wladim or in mahomes and now Kansas City
traded up to ten and took mahomes which
pushed
Lattimore to us but once we were at pick
10 with those two players we were
assured one of those two players but if
they took Lattimore they if Kansas City
took Lattimore more sweet had taken my
homes okay we'd had taken my homes and
had both of them let's say Kansas said
he just took player X we'd have taken a
lotta more we had the higher grade on
the corner okay have you talked to Drew
Brees about that possibility yeah you
know I think I think he understands like
anybody that the the importance of just
scouting in looking closely at value and
and I think it wouldn't has been him as
much as hey we need Drew's replacement
right here we just felt like this was a
really really talented player yeah and
time had sort itself out as to when he
got to the field but we try to do that
each year and certainly there's a sense
of urgency I think by every for every
team to have that position right you
know to have because they touch the
also many times you know that there's so
much that goes into that position and
you know we we had high grades on
Garoppolo and in when he got selected it
just wasn't in the wheelhouse with where
we were picking and but I do get guarded
with the idea well if we don't get our
quarterback at 11 then we'll just get
the next graded quarterback well what if
the next one isn't someone you love you
know and that's that's where I think you
sometimes can get into making mistakes
and you're you're you're you're strictly
reaching for need as opposed to you know
who do you have a conviction on in that
that first round a year ago when you go
through it man and there are a lot of
players in that first day I mean guys
that you thought were man safetex
that the jury's still out or the team
wouldn't do it again if they had it to
do over it's it wasn't it was about you
know your bat 300 last year in the first
round and I you can't do that especially
if you're looking in Cleveland Browns so
totality of it all and when you do that
you put it up it's it's alarming then
you start looking at well why why didn't
this guy make it or in year one why
wasn't he successful and I'm sure injury
played a part with a few of the players
but you know we were fortunate with
Lattimore at 11 and then Ram chick at 32
yeah I you know there's probably five
players other players than those two in
round one where you'd say we're man
surefire team would do it again the same
way and that's the alarming part of the
drill and in so trying to find the right
the right value but also the vision for
the player and your offense or defense
if you're the Browns what would you do
it one listen I think this if let's
start with the quarterback if they love
one you got to take one but would you
take darn 'old knowing that they need a
quarterback
they got tyrunt - yeah III would I
wouldn't be afraid of making that
selection because I know
look it's one but that's the cost of
sushi you know that's just the expense
in in you know it's a first round
quarterback let's look at it that way
and I know it's picked one but but let's
say Donald's the only quarterback in
this year's let's hypothetically say
he's the only one that's going to become
a successful NFL quarterback now and you
you go a different direction and then it
for fall back on a quarterback that
let's just say doesn't work out I think
I think that's a risky proposition as
opposed to I'm taking the quarterback
and then I'm going to really look
closely at this next available player
whether it's I don't think the running
back gets there
whether Chuck gets you know whoever's
graded next defensively or offensively I
just think that you got to secure that
position if your conviction is such on
the player and I think I think Donald's
gonna have a real good pro career I do
final 30 seconds if I had a vote by the
coaches to get rid of the kickoff still
keep the onside kick but get rid of
kickoffs how do you think coaches would
vote well I think the coaches would vote
against I think where we're all that as
a league I think in this this is pretty
easy I think we're we're at a place
where man we would we have to number one
we have to not eliminate the opportunity
for a team to score kick an onside kick
recover and score I would argue some of
the most exciting games in the last 25
years thirty years have been that I can
remember as a young I'm dating myself
now but back when the 49ers in the 70s
had John Brodie and Jean Washington it
was the weekend of the Immaculate
reception so 20 minutes before the 49ers
lose a close game to the Cowboys Frank
Harris gets the ball deflected he scores
a touchdown and all of a sudden the
Steelers advance not the Raiders this
was like the worst case scenario for the
two bay area teams
I'm a young 49ers fan probably eight or
nine years old they have a 13-point lead
I want to say Roger Staubach enters the
game at Candlestick at halftime leads
the team back in they score onside kick
recover and score no different than how
Seattle beat Green Bay and so that
element you don't want people at the
six-minute mark leaving games because
they know even if you score you'll
immediately have a possession then on
your own 20 or 25 yard line so we have
to protect that element of being able to
get the ball back so I can score twice
within two minutes if you will and now
it's it's looking at the play or the
event that takes place when that onside
kicks not happening can we and I and I
think to Troy's credit and the leaks
credit and now being involved in it
directly on the competition committee I
think within the next month we're
sending a group of people together for a
day and a half to look at what other
options in regards to alignment what
other options we can do in regards to
what we now know was a traditional
kickoff what can we do with that play
that keeps it exciting and right now
it's it's a play that's five times more
likely to you're going to get injured on
that play or have an injury or an event
so I think that the discussion is great
I think whatever takes place you know
balls on the 25-yard line unless you
choose to onside kick or we're going to
create more of a punt or but we're going
to brainstorm on that for a while before
we get to where we're just flat out
eliminating it in and I think that's the
right thing so I think the coaches vote
today would be would be no but it would
be with an asterisk saying Haley
explore ways to save it have fun on
Thursday night Shawn we appreciate your
time as always thanks for joining us Dan
thank you let's say Sean Payton Saints
head coach Continental Tire coaches
corner brought to you by Continental
Tire exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick
show for more information Continental
Tire kaam Continental Tire for what you
do for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]